hey guys I think we all come to a point
in our life when we have to ask
ourselves what do I believe now some of
us kind of ignore the question or
frankly aren't really that interested in
the answer hi Anne um I'm new in town
and I was just wondering if maybe you'd
like to
okay some of us so passively searching
kind of afraid of what we'll find why
not find and then there are others who
actively seek out and commit to their
beliefs
hello
who is this
and
I love you I wanted a moment I'd like
you show me with your love now I'm not a
religious person but I do believe that
having faith in something is important
whether that's faith in God Allah or
Darth Vader I think we all need
something to believe in but more
importantly than that I feel like we
have to meet each other's religious
beliefs with tolerance and understand
huh hello my name is elder price and I
would like to share with you this most
amazing book except the Mormons never
tolerate the Mormons stay awesome Gotham
we kid the movies don't we Congress
we're just kidding woman don't get mad
woman